AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT
GAME, WORST JOBS IN AMERICA.
WORST JOBS IN AMERICA.
THE ANNUAL LIST OF THE 25 BEST
JOBS IN AMERICA FOR 2015 WAS
PUBLISHED TODAY BY EMPLOYMENT
REVIEW SITE GLASSDOOR.
GLASSDOOR IS BELOVED BY JOB
SEEKERS AND HATED BY CARELESS
BIRDS TRAVELING AT TOP SPEED.
SOME GIGS AT THE TOP OFF THE
LIST -- WORDS ARE FUN AND WE CAN
PLAY WITHE THEM!
SOME GIGS AT THE TOP OF THE LIST
WERE PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT AND
SOFTWARE ENGINEER.
WHAT I WANT TO KNOW IS, WHAT ARE
THE 25 WORST JOBS.
COMEDIANS I WILL GIVE YOU A
LITTLE TIME, YOU GIVE ME AS MANY
TERRIBLE JOBS AS YOU CAN. AND
BEGIN.
MICHELLE.
>> THE GUY UNDER MY PODIUM RIGHT
NOW.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
>> TO THE LEFT, TO THE LEFT.
>> CHRIS: NIKKI GLASER.
>> GATHERING OF THE JUGGALO'S
BATHROOM ATTENDANT.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
MOSHE.
>> WORST OUTSIDE JOB IS
DEFINITELY A ROOFER IN SUMMER.
WORST INSIDE JOB, 9/11.
>> CHRIS: POINTS, POINTS.
NIKKE GLASER.
>> SKY MALL COP.
( LAUGHTER ).
>> CHRIS: POINTS, POINTS.
MICHELLE.
>> THE GUY THAT HAD TO TASTE THE
FIRST COUPLE TRIES OF BILL
GATES' POOP WATER.
>> CHRIS: POINTS, POINTS.
MOSHE.
>> IGGY AZALEA BLACCENT COACH.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
NIKKI.
>> A MOM.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
>> THAT'S NOT A JOB!
>> IT'S THE HARDEST JOB.